[Music]
a mattress pad protects and preserves a
mattress
ensuring that it lasts longer quilted
with plush filling
a mattress pad can also provide an extra
layer of comfort for those who prefer a
softer mattress
purchasing a comfortable mattress is an
investment in a good night's sleep
a mattress pad can protect that
[Music]
investment
to manufacture a mattress pad a crew
first cut straps to keep the fibers
compressed
then they feed the clumps of fibers into
a revolving drum with steel spikes
the spikes fluff up the fibers
this starts the process of opening and
separating the strands
fans propel the fibers through duct work
in the ceiling
and into a chamber where they tumble
around
this process introduces more air further
separating the fibers
it also helps mix the new and recycled
fibers together
with a polyester binder
[Music]
next rollers with small metal teeth
align the fibers
[Music]
two streams of combined fibers merge and
enter a machine called a cross lapper
[Music]
here carriages lay the fibers
perpendicular to each other
[Music]
multiple layers of crisscrossed fibers
accumulate
creating a thick pile of polyester
rollers compress the layers of polyester
then the padding travels through a long
oven
that's heated to just under 400 degrees
the heat activates the binder and unites
the polyester fibers
[Music]
the polyester exits the oven and is
taken up by a big spool
[Music]
in the next stage the polyester wadding
unrolls
and travels between sheets of embossed
fabric
at the same time thread unwinds from 22
bobbins
the thread and polyester wadding head
into a quilting machine
[Music]
here 22 needles chain stitch a design
into the fabric and polyester wadding
the stitching creates pockets that hold
the filling in place
without it the stuffing would slide
around between the sheets of fabric
a circular blade slices the quilted
fabric to a width of 60 inches
the standard for a queen-sized mattress
[Music]
the edges of the quilted layers are left
open for inspection
at the next station fabric for the skirt
unwinds into a large
automated sewing machine it pulls
elastic threads tight as it sews them
into the nylon material
creating a rib pattern
[Music]
this turns the fabric into a stretchy
material
[Music]
a seamstress stitches this stretchy
material to the quilted rectangles
she uses an industrial sewing machine
that trims excess fabric as it sews
[Music]
she also sews a label into the seam it
contains manufacturing information and
washing instructions
these overlock stitches will encapsulate
the seam so that the fabric will not
unravel
she trims the bottom of the skirt by
hand and hems it
the mattress pad is complete and ready
for the quality control department
here an employee does random checks of
the workmanship
he examines the fit of the pad to a
mattress and looks for missing stitches
or defects
with his approval the mattress pad is
ready to leave the factory
it takes about 30 minutes to make one of
these mattress pads
with the job complete it's nap time
you